hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to inside now I know you
guys have been asking for this game for
a long time and I'm sorry for the delay
I meant to get to it sooner but I just
got so busy and in fact I'm prepping for
Comic Con right now which means that I'm
gonna go meet you guys any one's going
to San Diego say hi to me I'm gonna be
at the red giant booth while I'm there
um but also I tried to start recording
this just a little bit ago and this is
going to be really disgusting and
probably doesn't speak well to my
hygiene and how I take care of
everything in my room please don't judge
me there's something about the the color
scheme oh by the way that's very nice
there's so many nuanced animations in
this game that I absolutely love but
I'll get to the game in a second I get
to talk about this horrifying thing the
color scheme made this glare appear on
my monitor and made me finally notice
all the spit that has been collecting on
my monitor over the years and there's no
easy way to say it I had to stop
recording it clean it up
so I'm sorry this is totally not to do
with the game it's just the reality of
my life right now and this is about as
far as I got when I've started playing
it before so this is made by the same
people by truck I actually don't know
why you're leaving or where I am
oh there's a guy in the background hello
am I supposed to do something about that
is that good or bad okay so this is made
by the same people that made limbo and
if you remember limbo limbo actually
came out about the time when I was first
starting to do YouTube maybe even before
that I can't remember the actual date
but it's one of the earliest Let's Plays
I ever did and limbo always will hold a
special place in my heart because limbo
hello was dude hi
what happens if I step out in front
hello hi oh hey thanks stranger danger
laughs oh God oh okay well that's no
good I don't even know why I'm hiding I
don't know why
would be looking for me what was with
his mask that's so weird
are so cool oh it's fascinating it's
fascinating because there's a lot of
like I said nuanced animation that's
going on in the background and it's
really cool to see because it's not
emphasizing this is in the same way that
limbo was there's a lot of stuff
happening in the environment in the
world even though it's like a 2d
side-scrolling deal like the world is
alive and it felt alive and in limbo it
was a horrifying shadow world that
consumed children and killed everybody
around you and had horrifying monsters I
guess it's okay you're going now
what is that Oh what is that it's like
some sort of power doohickey ooh it's so
weird looking into the distance and
seeing the shadows of the trees really
gives us eyes to the force oh yeah and
limbo had the things going in the
foreground sometimes it's so cool bye
this is important I can jump I can jump
oh I remember the yumping and the
bushing oh it came from limbo and also
whoa what was that wait I I did
something with it
did I do something or is that just my
imagination II oh wow I just slapped my
face of Crozet yeah okay so can i push
this can i boost this please oh no I
thought I could boost it up to the wall
and then jump over oh there's a doggy
over there oh what a good pop who's a
good pop over there I'll be with you in
a moment I got to find a way around do I
ever use button yeah I'm not a hundred
percent certain but maybe there's
something backtrack that I could
possibly do now I don't know anything
about this game other than like everyone
said that it's a phenomenal successor to
limbo
I don't know how closely it relates or
if at all I am NOT under present sure
that it does oh ah well I'm a hundred
percent wrong and I'm already lost I
just started this game but when I say
that my it was like baby mark a buyers
first edit was me making my webcam black
and white but it only took me until the
third episode to figure out that I
needed to do that but it was fascinating
to see because
was like the first moment where I
realized oh my god my editing influences
the experience that you guys have in
this game and the reason I made a black
and white cos old games black and white
okay I see the puzzle pieces I just got
to slide them together
how the Frick toy ah oh oh control okay
I didn't know that okay
there was no there's no control
instruction manual so III didn't know
that was something I needed to do okay
huh boom I boosted I boost it so good
hi doggy are you gonna notice me you
gonna come running after me
whoo-whoo-whoo-whoo-whoo
man it's so awesome the way makes things
seem distant sorry speaking been a
minute
anyway it's just the depth of the world
is very fascinating and I might have
said it but I'm not under presents sure
why this child is running away hello
okay YUM no bouche Oh something's going
on over there maybe I got to make a
running jump for it let's give it a go
pet mirskiy nope that ain't it okay so
if that's not it then I gotta find
another way because I don't think I can
make that jump and I don't oh maybe this
box maybe I can feel it I can't pool it
I'm gonna pull the box okay get out no
no no hey hey hey I thought that box is
gonna come crashing down on me
caboose key hey Biscay there we go and
away we go
hello yeah okay time for swimming hi can
you see me oh maybe I'm escaping whoo
well that doesn't sound good
uh-huh oh god that's not good what
happens if the puppy gets beep aah oh
god oh god
I mean I don't know I expected anything
else
Oh God oh good Oh so scary that puppy is
so angry yeah okay quick thinking haha
ah I got it huh huh huh huh
serves you right for trying to Myrtle
eyes me well I don't think there's
anything left for me here
so I might as well just keep moving
forward and forget about trying to find
all the deaths cuz I mean that that that
was a thing about the original limbo was
there were so many ways to die it was
just kind of fascinating to find them
all it's like it was an experience just
to go through the world and die in super
horrible ways which is something then I
was very good at doing if I remember
properly I gotta go back and watch that
probably probably will while I'm in San
Diego just going back not that I'm so
narcissistic that I watch my old videos
all the time but I do go back every once
in a while do experience memories and
get some good anon just gonna go on down
my memory and run alone I I'm done
diddly diddly diddly deee hun ha ha ha
ha I knew what to do I figured out I
used my human brain okay but you shall
not find me I mean you'll probably kill
me a whole bunch of times more in the
future but for now faceless chat over
here is gonna go meandering to success
unless the Internet has already given
this kid a name in that case it's
whatever name that you've chosen this
kid's name to be if he doesn't have a
name for himself hello ah what's going
on here hello someone hopped out of
there and they're oddly school are they
gonna see me if I cross in front of
their lights so what does that mean for
me I don't know but everyone better be
quiet
yeah any good hey hey stranger danger
stranger danger jump okay stranger
danger
that's right oh hey good oh hi oh why
was that necessary
that seemed absolutely unnecessary was I
supposed to go in the minivan or
something okay
probably yeah okay so there's gotta be
there's gotta be blue
okay so there's got to be something to
do with this minivan I I would imagine
oh oh ah oh geez oh geez oh geez
oh well this poor kid this poor kid has
me to control him that ain't good
I mean I um I yump to get away from the
branch and I know this one should be a
much more fluid experience for you guys
but I'm just as panicked as you offer
I'm just as terrible and horrible as you
don't do it yeah I him you guys can't
jump as good as I'm jumping I'm a
professional yam per hippie Oh ha
don't shoot me why would you do that be
nice be friendly be kind rewind oh this
is a whole bunch of bad okay
sploosh oh we are underwater now oh it's
like out of this world
nice oh man that's so cool oh did I
drown hot [ __ ] god dammit I was too
focused on having fun
hey bill DeMaio they'll never find me
they'll never ever find me never ever
and now I get good breath hi I'm running
away from you have a good day huh when
I'll die later don't worry don't worry
about me
I couldn't possibly survive in here is
there anything under water that I need
to know about cousin out of this world
there was horrifying tentacle monsters
from an alien planet trying to kill you
oh wow
that ain't good that's the opposite of
good sorry
don't know why I'm apologizing to a
couple dead pigs but sorry sorry oh man
is so cool just the environments the
environments and I actually like I
really do appreciate you know some
people would feel that it's limited to
go left to right but I appreciate the
fact that I don't have to like intensely
Explo intensely explore the environment
because this is the type of environment
it's so detailed and it seems so big
that I would personally want to go
around and wander everywhere but it's
nice because while it's kind of a to be
thing with puzzles in the middle it's
good that it keeps the flow of the game
moving forward times that's a measure
worried about okay alright carrying on
carrying on oh well that seems
relatively alright so what's all this
end whose farm is this on what dystopian
future do we exist in
oh man or all the animals - all God they
are all the animals are dead which
probably means those oh little animals
oh my god oh my god oh those are those
little birds are those little chickadee
Birds oh my god they're so cute
Oh oh there's so many of them I have a
bad feeling that there's suddenly gonna
turn feral and start eating me alive but
oh well oh my god there's so many hello
hi oh come with me Oh follow your new
mama okay is that a rope that I need
there we go oh no I'm sorry I hope you
do okay on your
own hurt better better epidermis herp
bender less oh there we go
okay ah I'm assuming the Flies are a
good thing and probably not to do with
any sort of death happening oh good I'll
pull this lever that sounds like fun
I like pulling levers nope and never on
this lever didn't want to be pulled what
about this crank can I yank this crank
no can I turn this work no okay well I
got a feeling that there's something to
do with that but I'm not on a person
sure what it's waiting for I would think
that it presented me with a cranky yank
and I'm supposed to yank the crank but
that's what everyone would think when
they're approached with a situation like
this
I know birdies maybe I need them I need
them of course of course I need them oh
of course
come on do the thing can you do the
thing what are you doing do this oh it's
only this control that does it oh I
thought it was a different control okay
see I was pressing the left control but
it's the right control that actually
needs to do the thing so that's good to
know
alright now I can push this thing it
really ought did nothing
I'm little birdies come with me I hope I
don't have to feed you into this oh
there seems to be a convenient ramp for
small creatures to walk into and I don't
know if that's a good thing
oh why is it making me do that
hahaha oh no oh no no no oh god oh no I
know what it needs me to do oh it's so
mean it's so mean oh oh they're alive oh
you're gonna be dead
oh no how did they survive that oh man I
thought they were gonna be turned into
meat and it was just gonna be a spray of
blood
oh my goodness I am so happy oh man I
was so I'm pretty sure they probably got
everyone with that and they did that
intentionally okay
just so long as we're on the same page
and everything's doing fine I'll jump
into that whoa
pig carcasses I don't like that all
right what do we get over here do I need
to go the other way probably towards
more pig carcasses which is always a
good thing
so it's either it's either these things
oh do I need to push the cart we have
pick carcasses that would be the obvious
thing to do so it's either whoa
you seen what I'm seeing yeah oh oh oh
there are worms
oh it's worms oh good ah oh so sorry my
skin too started crawling like you
wouldn't believe
Oh God oh uh why worms why so many worms
oh I hate worms worms orrible okay so
that answers a question there's some
horrible disease going through here an
infection I don't know if it affects the
whole world but it's bad do I gotta
crawl under it now I can climb okay that
makes sense
huh musky look well that makes it so
much worse
Oh No oh god they're so obvious now have
they always been there okay okay okay
okay all right
hello yep okey-dokey this now dammit ow
man how are you still wash [ __ ]
ow oh that one hurt well sorry I didn't
mean to do that
I meant to jump on you first okay so I
got I imagine I gotta jump off
ah [ __ ] oops
oh boy okay so I gotta get him to do
something else oh oh oh the worm oh the
worm oh oh did I help ha ha okay come
with me
oh you poor animal oh you poor animal oh
whatever
what are they oh my god I just noticed
oh what's with them what's wrong with
them
sorry there's something been in my eye
like an eyelash but what is wrong with
them oh my god oh that's horrible
oh no like that ah well oh yeah oh
alright then
sorry sorry okay lifting lifts okay how
am i controlling you how am i doing that
whoa that's weird
oh that's weird
oh whoa move alright um are you free now
can you go is it actually day oh my head
is in it I thought I was just holding on
to the thing Oh fascinating
okay so you all go in there be good all
right I'm a drop I guess there we go
whoo oh that's so weird
oh this world is fascinating oh this
world is delightful oh I'm very into
this I'm not even being sarcastic I am
so into this all very much I'll kid your
Strang you're so Strang oh and I love
how fluid it is oh I love how fluid it
is oh man it looks so uh mm-hmm love it
love it love it love it this is
phenomenal oh wow I haven't geeked out
about a game like this in a long time
that's disconcerting why are they being
loaded up is that what I was trying to
escape from what was that what was that
what's in here whoo okay that boo not
better that better have just been kelp
or some debris or some thort whoo no
wonder I'm running away oh my god so
there's some dark implication about
everything that's been going on here
some bad stuffs hanging around here move
all right let's do it
I feel you oh no but it's a catch-22 if
one is the way that it was maybe I got a
boo [ __ ] I'll Boosh it if I Boosh it all
the way maybe it's gonna go down
er ah boo stick dude coming up on the
Comi hip okey yeah mmm man this kid's
got some strength
I guess if he's gonna be a survivor he's
got to be strong okay and I got it you
did okay yep
Hey yep yup one more come on you got it
you got it buddy
okay so now that we're here did we go
bashing through that window like
gangbusters Wow sorry
maybe I pick up this chair no mm maybe I
open the window like a civilized person
yep
that's that's what I do here I was gonna
smash my skull against the window and
get charged of glass in my eyes whereas
this guy was logical and smart that's
why he would survive a scenario not me
is that gonna fall on me sure sounds
like it
oh no apparently I'm fine yeah I keep
looking out for traps and I'm pretty
sure it's that's by design because in
the last game there was were a lot of
traps whoo hello mm-hmm okay so what
happens if I go right I probably die
right
I'll probably die this will kill me
it'll probably kill me ow ow oh oh that
was bad well I'm an idiot let's try that
again shall we with a little less stupid
I mean it's still gonna have a heaping
helping of stupid don't you worry about
that any markiplier let's play comes
with a free complimentary side of stupid
but in this one for this kids sake just
a little less
okay so hey ah okay so I got a blue [ __ ]
in some capacity to try to make
something go wumpy so if I can make
something go wumpy ah I can you um pawn
that and that'll be good enough for Bao
that'll be good enough in a little I'm
just hippity hopping all the way in the
chem shop but the speedrunners baby
parkour parkour huh okay then hippity
hop all the way over here to the gaming
shop which this over on the unsuspecting
villain hey birdies
I never mind I don't want to kill you
hit me ow
when I was dumb a funny feeling that
something bad was gonna happen okay so
maybe I got a run after a boo [ __ ] oh
geez well that was almost certain death
I'm pretty sure that was probably
another way that I could have gone about
that but it would have been nearly as
fun let's not think about the dangerous
let's think about the foon just remember
still a lot of stupid oh that's so cool
there's like didn't I dynamic they're
dynamic andaman nation's dynamic
animations it's cool it's awesome
alright let's give it a scat scat back
you ow
my ankles all right what do we got here
hello whoa ah woo that was handy
whatever that was I am really strong
considering I just ripped that off its
hinges what's down here I don't agree or
there's something down there I saw a guy
I don't like it when I see people I
would have again here hello Oh
I didn't mean to I just keep pulling on
random things why can't you make me
Boosh I'm good at Bhushan ain't good at
Poland god dammit I didn't mean to I'm
sorry I don't know what I did but I did
it whoa did I see something
oh no that's like boxes I thought I saw
someone standing in the darkness back
there but apparently not that would have
been terrifying they would have been
horrifying neither this game hasn't been
thoroughly horrifying this entire time
but not this time
ooh hope that did something good is that
shadows I see on the other side over
there
well that's probably bad hit hit me okay
stick my head in here somehow I know how
to use this and somehow it's able to
hold me up by my gosh darn it
whoever Deewani with me what happened II
whoo buddy boink oh I thought there was
gonna be something going on there
okay we bdy buddy will be dy buddy would
you would you move with you okay so the
problem is they're not in sync so we
need to figure out a way to get them in
the right equidistance ole so that they
can go to where they need to go okay so
it's got to be something to do with that
lever right right
it's got to be something to do with the
lever so this lever oh it's about good
okay good enough I almost chopped that
guy right in half but this oops but this
is how it's done probably hit me okay so
if I I gotta move
let's see
it did dit and then we come back in
we're good bada-bing bada-boom I know
what I'm doing it's not that difficult
but at least I did something huh
okay so now we keep moving on bye thank
you love you
uh I don't know whoa whoa that's not
good that's not good at all that's
probably it that's probably bad fight
against what something is that's
definitely bad good boy
oh boy okay yeah and like it don't like
it no laggy okay oh where am I going
down here oh it's just a surge of them
whoo I got the pipe mirrors edge up in
this [ __ ] you didn't hear a thing don't
look up here don't be you dare don't you
look buddy oh that's so weird I mean
there's been a lot of dystopian futures
but I haven't really seen one where they
start hurting Oh people is cattle yeah I
felt like that could almost fall over
but I'm not under sin sure if that was a
case yeah the key moving okey-dokey
yeah oh boy oh boy yeah but oh I thought
that was gonna fall off too well
probably best to just keep moving anyway
because they probably heard something
about that and they're gonna come after
me very soon man this kid is going
places I don't know why he doesn't just
stop and hide but that probably wouldn't
help anybody that probably is very bad
oh man why and this seems like a recent
thing I mean number one there's worms
everywhere which I have a funny feeling
they're infected by some sort of mind
control worms hi oh man but another is
just that it's super bizarre everything
that's going on man got cool though but
either way that's all the time I got for
this episode I'm gonna be playing this
every single day this week while on the
comic-con so don't you worry about that
I'm gonna get there
very soon so thank you everybody so much
for watching as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
ha oh you miss me